After months of fierce and
bloody fighting,
Russian forces may be on the verge
of capturing
the eastern city of Borehamwood.
Even as Russian fighter
surround the city,
Ukrainian commanders are not withdrawing
and instead calling on President Zelensky
to send in reinforcements.
CNN's Alex
Marquardt is in eastern Ukraine.
Mercenary fighters from the Wagner Group
were seen
planting their flag
in the eastern part of the city.
Tell us about that
Well, hi there, Victor and Bianna.
Well, in the past few
days, Russian forces
have made some progress at encircling
not major,
but they have been pressing
forward to the north and to the south
around the city
and then pressing into the city
from the east.
We did see that new video
from the Viognier group.
Remember,
Wagner has been really leading the charge
when it comes
to Russian forces around Bermuda.
They removed the Ukrainian flag
from a monument.
They planted their own flag,
not the Russian flag,
but the Wagner flag,
and raised their guns in the air.
Meanwhile, we did hear from President
Zelensky's office tonight
saying that they continue
to defend their positions,
defend the city
and they talk about reinforcing
their positions.
They didn't talk about surrender,
but we have spent
a lot of time in that area over the past
few days.
We spent a lot of time
on the main
supply route
between the neighboring town of Chelsea
VR and Back Mount.
There's a lot of military traffic
on that road.
I can tell you
that it is getting very difficult
to move in and out of dark mood.
It is getting attacked by Russian forces.
They blew up a bridge on that main
supply route just a couple of days ago.
We were told by local officials today
that military engineers
have erected a temporary bridge
so troops are able to move forward
and back.
People are able to come out and go in
But it is getting much more difficult.
And Victor and Brianna,
you're starting to hear this line
despite the fact that no withdrawal
has been announced,
that even if Ukraine were to withdraw
that this would not actually be
a strategic victory
for Russia,
that they will have lost so many men,
they would have taken over this city
that doesn't actually
have any strategic value
that Ukraine is actually was able
to degrade Russian forces
and buy time for a planned.
That at
the end of the day,
according to us, and Ukrainian officials,
it would not be that strategic
a victory
for Russia,
but it really would
be a loss for Ukraine.
They also have lost
a lot of men in this fight.
They've lost professional soldiers. Why?
While on the Russian side,
so many of
the people who have been killed
have been convicts in the mercenary group
So at the end of the day,
this would be a symbolic victory
for Russia.
But it really is up for debate
how strategic it would be.
One last thing
I did
speak with the deputy
mayor of Baruch today
who said there are still some
four to 5000 people
who are still in the city.
They're trying to get as many out
as possible, around five to ten per day,
if they're lucky.
The people in there,
he says they simply don't want to leave
because they say
they don't know where they would go.
That they don't have any money.
They're scared.
They're scared,
scared to go out on that road.
And he said that his overwhelming feeling
when thinking about his city right now
is fear and sadness.
Victory on
this is a city
that was once home to tens of thousands
of Ukrainians. Alex Marquardt, thank you.
Well, let's bring in
CNN's Oren Liebermann,
who is at the Pentagon.
The or in the defense
secretary spoke out
about the situation in Baku today.
What is he saying?
This really echoes
the point
that Alex was making there
about the strategic value
or lack thereof when it comes
to the city of Mahmoud.
Defense Secretary Lloyd Austin,
who is now traveling in the Middle
East, said this wouldn't
be some strategic strategic victory
for Russia.
Simply because there isn't
that much strategic value to Obama
just given its location.
It doesn't
control the surrounding area
or have a lookout
that gives you a strategic advantage
and still Russia
is determined
to keep throwing as many lives
as it needs to.
It is to take Mahmoud.
But again,
Austin saying this wouldn't be a victory.
Listen to what he had to say here.
I would not view
that as a
as an operational or strategic setback.
I think it's more of a symbolic
value than it is strategic
and operational value.
What I do see on a daily basis is
the Russians continuing to pour
in a lot of ill trained
and ill equipped troops.
And those troops are very quickly
meaning their demise.
It is worth pointing out
that even if the city itself
doesn't have strategic value,
it is an important decision
where you decide where Ukraine that is
decides to fight Russian forces.
Right now,
Ukraine is making that decision
to fight in the city of Mahmoud
and that is an important
strategic decision.
Ukraine realizing
if they don't fight them
on the line in Bermuda
and they decide at some point to withdraw
and to move back towards the west.
That will simply be the new line
at which they fight the Russians.
And that perhaps
another reason
that they decided to hold
or at least fight for the city of Bermuda
as long as possible
as both sides suffer
very high losses here, Bianna and Victor.
We're anticipating
an offensive from the Ukrainians
sometime this spring as well.
Oren Liebermann, thank you.
General Wesley
Clark is a CNN military
analyst and former
NATO supreme allied commander. General.
Good to see you.
So I'm interested to get your take
because we heard
from the defense secretary today
saying that in his view,
a retreat from back
would not be an operational
or strategic setback for the Ukrainians.
And yet, at the same day,
we're hearing
that Ukrainian military officials
are advising President Zelensky
to continue
to send in reinforcements
to to fight for this city.
Is that a mistake on their part
at this point?
Well, it's really hard to second
guess us beyond because we're not there.
We don't see the terrain.
We don't see the ground now.
If you look at port mode
and you look west, it's several miles
to the next
really good, defensible terrain location.
And if they get there, if they fall back,
they're going to have to hold their
falling back.
A withdrawal under pressure
is one of the most difficult
military operations.
You suffer the risk of a catastrophic
collapse and big losses when you do this.
So it does make some sense.
And I can understand
the logic of the Ukrainians
in wanting to hold where they are
as long as they can
they are inflicting heavy,
heavy casualties on the Russians.
We don't see
the answer is
we don't see what's behind
the initial Russian assault
We don't see the forces in depth
arrayed back there.
We also don't know how
the Ukrainian command
is building up its own forces
for the counteroffensive
and how much it can whittle away.
That force is necessary
to reinforce and be moot.
So there's a lot of intangibles here
and things
that we just don't
have the information on.
I do agree with Secretary State.
It's probably not a great,
from our perspective, operational
or tactical loss
but it is a psychological blow
and a psychological lift for Moscow.
And at some point,
these Russian troops have to be defeated.
They have to be held.
They have to be pushed back.
And so from the Ukrainian
military perspective,
it's a very understandable position
to hold the line as long as possibly can
I'm glad you brought up that planned
spring offensive that everyone's
anticipating from the Ukrainians,
because I'm wondering,
listen, from
a cost benefit perspective,
one could argue that the past few months
really did benefit Ukraine
to continue fighting in back mode
because you lost a lot of Russian men
and a lot of Russian troops
and ammunition as well.
That they invested in their battle
for that city.
But at some point,
it does turn
and you see the reflection
upon Ukrainians
who are also losing their troops
there at an enormous rate
and their ammunition.
Do you think the longer they
maintain this fight for Obama,
do you think it could impact
whatever counteroffensive
they're planning
Well, it
certainly could, but
they have to hold in the east.
They do not want to surrender Donbas
if they do.
They're just going to have
to fight further West.
So they've got prepared
defensive positions here.
They've got stockpiles.
They know the routes.
This is an advantageous way to hold
for as long as they can.
Look, we are
there's no doubt that the Russians
have superiority of artillery.
Well,
certainly Ostrom has acknowledged that.
The thing is, they're firing.
They have more artillery tubes
and they're far more ammunition
on a daily basis than the Ukrainians.
We just got to get them more help.
And until that time,
they're going to have
a hard time holding.
And the Ukrainians are taking casualties.
But this is war and it's their country,
and they want to hold it.
It is proving to be very difficult
to procure the amount of ammunition
that that Ukraine
is requiring at this point.
Here's how one military expert
described Russia as at all costs.
Battle for Obama.
Assuming that Ukrainians
at some point do retreat.
Here's what he wrote.
The reality is that if the Russians do
capture Obama,
they are seizing rubble
It is a town with minimal
strategic importance,
with almost no remaining infrastructure
to support an occupying force
that the Russians have invested
so much in.
Its capture
speaks volumes
about their poor strategy in this war.
Would you agree with that assessment?
I'm a little
cautious about that assessment.
The honor,
because it is written
from the Western perspective.
If you had 500,000 people
and you lost 30,000
people, 40,000
people in a month,
and you talk about what you might say
that's insignificant,
If you were a Russian commander,
now, if you're an American commander
or Ukrainian commander
and you're losing 30,000 troops
over that piece of ground,
that's really significant.
But if you're a Russian commander
and they're pushing those troops forward
and they use them up usual, use them off
and you get a break through in dark mode,
or you significantly degrade
the Ukrainians
on balance, from the Russian perspective,
it might be worth it.
So I think we have to be
a little cautious about critiquing
Russian tactics from our perspective.
Yeah, from Russia's perspective,
these troops are expendable.
There's talk about another conscription
perhaps coming this summer.
General Wesley Clark, thank you so much.
Always great to have you
on and your analysis.